do you know what sets you apart from the
rest of the others as an employee or as
a job seeker
it is your set of soft skills more often
than not
many of us overlook the importance of
soft skills and pay more attention to
hard skills
and experience however soft skills are
vital for an employee
and for that matter for every individual
this video will list a set of soft
skills that will help you grow
in your career so what are soft skills
these are skills that refer to various
personality traits such as attitude
communication critical thinking time
management
creative abilities etc soft skills help
in capitalizing on your potential and
help you stand out
all those educational certifications
don't matter if you are poor at these
soft skills
hence you must groom your soft skills
after careful analysis
we list the top 5 most important soft
skills a job seeker
or an employee must have one first and
foremost
you must possess good communication
skills both written and
verbal being a good communicator is
crucial in any workplace
having strong communication will boost
your chances of building healthy
relationships with your co-workers
you can enhance your communication and
presentation skills by joining various
public speaking workshops
two next up is your adaptability one
thing you should always remember is that
your work might not go as
planned hence you need to be flexible
and be adaptable to accommodate new
changes and find alternate solutions
to be adaptable you need to be an
adopter for change
and keep up with the pace the world runs
at employers look for professionals who
are capable of meeting new challenges
and who create new benchmarks three
third in our list is
problem solving and critical thinking so
what do you do when you confront a
problem in your workplace
do you [ __ ] about it or do you look for
a solution
hope your answer is to look for a
solution because that is exactly what
you get noticed and make you an asset in
an organization
to be a problem solver always think of
solutions and not the problem
critical thinking is also another
important skill you need to bring new
perspectives and well thought out
solutions to help the company progress
to do this well learn to analyze and
critically observe
every situation four next on our list is
teamwork
the success of every company depends on
the hard work of all of its employees
every employee is different and each of
them has their own set of strengths
it works best for an organization when
all the employees collaborate and
capitalize on their talents and work
together towards a common goal
this way everyone wins office culture
also primarily depends on
team players furthermore you should
always be able to collaborate well with
your co-workers
which strengthens your work quality to
be a good team player
always extend a helping hand to your
colleagues which will surely help you
someday
5. the last skill set on our list is
time management
the old saying goes time and tide wait
for no man is indeed very true
every job has its tight deadlines and
pressure
employers look for candidates who can
deliver good results within a stipulated
time and
set stress aside nobody wants to have an
employee who doesn't meet deadlines
yes you should do your work well but at
the same time keep in mind the deadlines
you must be able to manage your time
well to provide fruitful results
time management can also help when you
work under pressure
if you efficiently organize and
prioritize your task you will manage
your time
well and deliver your work on time this
way
your employer will have faith in you and
give you more crucial responsibilities
so those were our set of the top five
soft skills every professional must have
apart from these skills it would be best
if you always remember to carry a
positive attitude
even when things might fall apart it is
of utmost
importance that you carry a positive
outlook which will surely help you
overcome your problems
soft skills help build a reputation
opening the door to more opportunities
that you can
ever imagine so don't just rely on those
educational certificates to grow in your
career
instead make sure that you incorporate
these soft skills
and you will surely see how different
your life will be
so that brings us to the end of this
video i hope these tips are helpful to
all of you out there
and i wish you all the very best thank
you for watching the video and stay
tuned for more from simply learn